foreign
there's a cool thing happening in this
scene in Jordan peels nope you may
notice it starts out pretty dark
then slowly gets brighter here you can't
see the logo on OJ's hat but two minutes
later in a nearly identical shot you
can't
it's an incredibly subtle trick that
cinematographer hoyta van hoytoma used
to emulate how our eyes naturally
respond to Darkness we build up a sort
of Fades in that are very slow but that
simulate very much your pupil dilations
but what makes this subtle trick
possible is that this nighttime scene
was shot in the daytime
day for night is a technique Hollywood
is used for years but it hasn't always
produced convincing results or clearly
visible ones as seen in shows like House
of the Dragon
[Music]
so how did Hollywood get to this point
here you might be wondering why wouldn't
filmmakers just film their nighttime
scenes at night
and in reality many do taking advantage
of artificial lighting and today's more
sensitive digital camera sensors but
neither modern digital camera sensors
nor traditional film have the
sensitivity of the human eye in low
light scenarios that means that often
when night scenes are filmed in natural
lighting conditions very little of the
shot is visible
this is why Hollywood often films what's
called day for night shooting nighttime
scenes in daylight and using cinematic
techniques to create the illusion of
Darkness Francois true foe even paid
homage to the technique in a movie
called day for night
one standard way to shoot day for night
is by filming against a blue screen and
creating a totally CG environment but
many filmmakers like Jordan Peele on
nope want the grounded reality of
shooting as much as possible out in the
field when shooting on location
traditional day for night techniques
typically involve manipulating the color
grading adding a bluish tint and upping
the contrast on the image until it
resembles night we're using smoke dust
or sand and creating fake Silhouettes
the most famous examples of these
techniques all shared a similar
challenges note filming on location in
vast desert Landscapes capturing
expanses of land and sky that are just
too big to light when filming at night
but the combination of these techniques
can create a slightly artificial look
one that Jordan and hoita refer to as
movie Nights they noticed the movie
night's aesthetic in their visual
references for note including older
westerns and the 1962 film Lawrence of
Arabia there's big day for night Seekers
the Lawrence of Arabia and it's great is
wrong it's people from Camels and quite
fast Landscapes and we realize very
quickly we wanted that scope but we
didn't want that look but to go beyond
the limited aesthetic of traditional day
for night filming they'd have to get
much more Technical and creative
their goal was to capture the way the
human eye sees at night not the way a
camera sees like the way our eyes
gradually adjust to Darkness stare at
this dark shape or for that matter just
imagine it turns out just thinking about
dark spaces can start to dilate our
pupils so that we can take in more
visual information
like nope Mad Max Fury Road emulated
this transition subtly by starting its
night scene out pretty dark to sell the
night then slowly making it brighter
once our eyes are adjusted there's the
question of how to replicate the level
of fine detail that we can perceive at
night Productions often struggle to nail
this down especially because when
filming day for night DP is usually
under expose the scenes by three or four
stops planning to make them as dark as
possible
however under exposed day for night
scenes are often rendered so dark to
compensate for the daytime that you can
barely make out anything at all
audiences have complained about this
limited visibility in modern TV shows
like House of the Dragon which was shot
in full day and then darkened a lot in
post
selective use of light can help make
scenes more legible to viewers in Pan's
Labyrinth DP Guillermo Navarro was going
for an eerie effect so he drilled tiny
holes in the sets to allow some light to
leak in and the giant frog scene he lit
Ophelia's face with a fiber optic light
attached directly to the camera
other films have gone the opposite
direction Mad Max wanted viewers to be
able to follow every shot of its big
nighttime set piece so the team
massively Overexposed the photography to
ensure they captured all the detail in
the shadows the effect worked well on
Mad Max because of the dynamic range of
the digital cameras used on the film and
because of the stylized night look that
they were going for which was supposed
to look realistic but not photorealistic
so they could afford to make it less
dark and more blue Mad Max also used a
lot of Sky Replacements and skies are in
fact often the biggest giveaways when
filming day for night when a scenes
darkened in post the skies often still
look bright relative to the rest of the
shot so we can feel the day leak through
to create authentic night skies on no
hoyta pulled from earlier work on Ad
Astra where he had experimented with
infrared cameras to create the black
Skies of the moon chase sequence there's
very little alien light on the moon so
it's a very weird hybrid of day and
night we needed to shoot a Rover Chase
on the moon's surface which is a
gigantic area something we couldn't
light up so you end up with a black and
white image that has very good light
levels and a light relationship between
lightness and darkness but then you have
to figure out a way to get color back
and you could think about coloring it by
hand but we were thinking well we're
shooting this on film what if we could
combine those two cameras together and
then just mix the color back in
selectively where we want it you use one
camera to tell you the relationship of
the light levels between everything and
then you use the other camera to gather
like color information and build brain
and such things by shooting natural
sunlight with infrared cameras and then
giving it a slight contrast boost you
end up with images that are brightly lit
but with dark skies which worked
perfectly for nope
yeah
but this time poita had to restructure
the rig for the super heavy large format
cameras that he and Jordan were working
with so we ramped it up because this one
we showed 65 millimeter film so we have
to rebuild the rig for a 65 millimeter
film camera while the cameras were ready
to shoot the rig was heavy and pretty
unbalanced and a lot of the night
sequences in nope were major action set
pieces where the crew had to follow
running horses and actors and couldn't
be limited in how they could move the
rig around so they stabilized the rig by
attaching it to a specially retrofitted
camera car a lot of the action that we
shoved over the field we shot from an
instrument called the etch it's a car
with an arm which has a very big
stabilized head on there the rig also
allowed for a more Dynamic shoot by
addressing one of the limitations of
traditional day for night needing the
sun exactly in the right place when
filming
typically depending on the time of day
the sun can cast harsh overly dramatic
Shadows that filmmakers want to avoid if
you do traditional day for nights the
quality of the image is so dependent on
your light Direction day for night works
very nice if you have backlits it works
not very well if you're front lips
typically filmmakers get around this by
carefully positioning the actors with
their backs to the Sun to create a rim
light effect that resembles Moonlight
with the infrared brick we found that it
was much easier we didn't have to be as
precious about my direction as you
traditionally need to be for day for
night in post the VFX team merged the
digital infrared footage with the color
film footage in a process that almost
resembles colorizing an old black and
white movie except instead of inventing
the colors they could extract them from
the film camera photography which
captured all the vital color and texture
information
allowed the filmmakers on nope to
capture more detail important for how
Jordan wanted the audience to experience
the movie
instead of pushing the Thriller forward
by relying on the blunt force of The
Dark Knight and sound effects he wanted
to encourage the audience to actively
look into the darkness and start seeing
things for themselves
to hide things in the shadow you know
and there's Darkness but you see just
what the cinematographer knee should see
but here we want to at first put you at
a place
and give you that scope and then within
that sort of play with these these
little elements
combining the color with the infrared
also helped the team nail the correct
relationships between light and dark
parts of each shot we were of course
being very analytical about how your eye
perceives different colors at night the
way that for instance foliage and green
is much brighter at night than a lot of
other colors the fact that the lights on
ground level is very often brighter than
what you get from the sky you know the
Sky plays a very big role in though so
we also want to be able to feel the sky
and feel the differences in density and
where there's overcast whereas clouds or
where there's Moonlight etc etc in post
the team sprinkled in additional details
to emphasize the full richness and depth
of the night scenes visual effects when
back at night shocked very specific
plates of practical lights in the
distance to then add it to those
pictures and for me these little things
are really the Cherry toppings on the
cake it totally completes it and sort of
finishes it looking after the mountain
which there's these Telegraph poles and
they have these tiny little red blinking
lights on them and in your monochromatic
view of nights you see those little red
dots blinking and suddenly you're
looking at a picture that has full
saturation to it and and and full depth
but one last piece was missing this is
shelving in California and you'll get
very little clouds the story of nope is
very specific at the mouse game in which
Gene jacket is hiding in clouds and
moving from One Cloud to the other so
the VFX team added digital cloudscapes
created from modular sets of hundreds of
3D modeled clouds altered to match the
light of the combined infrared color
footage the VFX team also added drifting
Shadows of the clouds to connect the sky
with the ground and in nope this Tech
and partnership between camera and
visual effects made the movie Nights
feel every bit as real immersive and
expansive as how Jordan and hoita
experienced them on location
oh
[Music]
foreign